the concept that the  world's oceans are in trouble  we've known about for a long time but  there seems to be a we don't care view  in large parts of the world or we  wouldn't keep polluting well it's not  just the oceans that are in trouble it  is the oceans contribution to the rest  of man scientists vary between 50 and 80  percent of the oxygen comes from the  ocean  25  of all carbon uh sequestration comes  from the ocean so if we don't take care  of the oceans it's like losing your  lungs practically so you ask the  question of why am i doing this or why  am i excited about it and that is  because i think if people get excited  like i did with jacques or many of my  generation did  then they will care about it so i the  exciting them is great the  bringing them beyond excitement to  caring about it would be great